look you're going on I saw one once was
it it what so fluffy I thought I was
gonna die happy Mother's Day
okay yeah we're fine are you sorry went
a little mama bear on you have a good
one from Despicable Me for you pretty
peachy so how are things career-wise
the fire it's time to get back on topic
we're going back to villainy
the feeling um so brother how are things
career-wise crashing it get your mojo
back
we're going back to villainy you two are
villains now I mean hello speedy rated
PG how could you let beltasar brat just
get away you're fired
he really did miss Douglas I admit what
are you doing since you don't have a job
I just wanted your help
uh excuse me hmm
hey could you oh oh oh of course
Wow as I was saying I good my seriously
Wow I really must have a word with you
on behalf of your twin brother drew what
wind brother hey brother
my god way to meet my
[Music]
give what's the difference between
having loves it
look at him Elvis hair would make you
better sex he's so mad you might be the
beautiful wife oh wait talker this place
is amazing
it's nice like gasps yah I'm not really
interesting bro you're losing blood
it grows on boobs you ready to continue
the family tradition
you and me no I left that life behind me
just one
[Music]
I'm going in okay
it does not mean that you're going back
to being village
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you